hey guys dr. Burke here I wanted to
create a video for those individuals who
do not like vegetables and I am that
person I never did I still don't but I
eat a lot of vegetables okay but let's
talk about it why don't people like
vegetables first of all it's time
consuming you have to prepare it you
have to cut the vegetables it's a pain
in the butt and then they don't really
taste that great they don't give you a
lot of pleasure
lots of chewing if I if I didn't have to
get healthy and I and health wasn't a
problem and I get anything I want I
probably live on potato chips popcorn
Pizza salty foods on the salt person
right I wouldn't have any vegetables
well what happened is that I got in
trouble when I was in my 20s because I
did not consume the amount of vegetables
that I needed so really we the main
thing that we need from vegetables is
the nutrients the raw enzymes the
vitamins the minerals that's why we need
to consume them now if you have any
chance of restoring liver damage or even
losing weight you're going to have to
change your mind about vegetables and
consume a lot you cannot successively
long-term lose weight and get healthy
without vegetables it's impossible like
eating a little bit of cook this or
powder this or it's not going to cut it
you're going to have to eat vegetables
and I'm sorry but corn is not what I'm
talking about or peas you're not going
to get the amount of vegetables you need
actually at least half of these
vegetables raw okay so I understand
there's certain things that bloat people
and that's fine we can steam them but we
need some raw so you have to find
something that you consume that doesn't
blow you so there's a couple points I
want to make about this number one I do
get pleasure from eating vegetables but
an hour after I eat them or sometimes
even a day after I eat them the days
that I don't eat vegetables I feel more
sluggish heavier and bloated
like I ate too much protein and the days
that I eat it I just feel lighter I just
feel the difference I can perceive the
difference so personally I do it because
I've been convinced so many times that
it just makes me feel better and it's
actually doing good that I stick with it
so you have to just change your
viewpoint on this and just kind of start
eating more for a health and not
everything for pleasure all the time
right now there's a couple things that
you can do to make it easy on yourself
especially for the time like you don't
have time to prepare and I like to blend
my vegetables okay so I'm going to show
you a little quick recipe that you can
just basically take up a blender stick
them in there stick a couple other
things in there to make it taste good
blend it to them take it to work with
you drink it up and that way you don't
have to always have a sit down and eat
the salad and chew the whole thing all
right
so let's go to my house and I'll show
you how to make it hey guys we're at my
house and this is we're going to do
we're going to just basically take a
blender fill it up half with water this
is our kale look at how much kale this
is this is pretty much at least about
seven to eight cups so it's going to be
hard to eat this but it's easy to drink
it and I freeze it I'm just going to put
it in here and it's easy when you if you
freeze it it lasts a long time if you
don't it can go bad pretty quickly so
I'm going to blend just the kale in the
water first okay so let me show you some
okay so basically it's blended now if
you're not trying to lose weight or if
you're a child you could easily just put
fruit in here put a banana put berries
but if you're trying to lose weight you
can put some berries too but I do find
that that might slow down weight loss
for some people that have stubborn
metabolism so there's a couple options
you can take berry sweetened stevia and
put a couple drops in there my wife
likes chocolate but this is what I'm
doing lately it seems to work really
good the instant kale shake berry
I like this my wife likes the chocolate
but simply what we're going to do is
just after we blended it we're going to
take a scoop of berry and stick it in
there
and this is no sugar but it's sweet and
it has kale in it instant kale shake so
I put one scoop I'm just going to mix it
for a second and I'm done so now this
kale shake is pretty sweet and it's kale
and I wait for the foam to come down but
it tastes like it has berries in it and
there's no berries in it so it's a great
low sugar drink now you can drink your
salad you can bring this to work you
know drink it when you get home from
work and it's just an easier way to
avoid eating a huge amount of salad it's
a quick way to drink your salad and I
use the kale my wife likes to chocolate
one you can check that out and yeah so
that's just a little tip to be able to
consume more vegetables